[Music]
the nasal cavity the pharynx and the
larynx make up the upper respiratory
tract this is where we concluded the
previous part now it's time we have a
look at the lower respiratory system as
the air passes down the larynx it has to
travel far crossing many junctions in
between the first Junction is the track
here this is also called the windpipe
this is a slender muscular pipe that
lies just below the larynx it usually
makes up the throat region and extends
till the fifth thoracic vertebra post
this it gets divided into two branches
the trachea is surrounded by rings of
cartilage it is the hyaline cartilage
that surrounds the windpipe which gives
both strength and flexibility to the
tracheal muscles if the structure is
observed from the dorsal view then the
cartilage rings are found to be
incomplete that is they are C shaped and
do not form a complete ring like
structure this helps in easy contraction
of the muscles when the food is passed
down the esophagus like just behind the
trachea at the point where the trachea
is about to terminate it's the next
Junction that arrives this is called the
bronchus as we can see here bronchus
acts like the entry point in the lungs
it gets divided into two branches called
the right main bronchus and the left
main bronchus which is the right
anguishes the left by the way well here
we're referring to the structures with
respect to the human body that has the
system in other words if this individual
is standing in front of you then this is
the right and this is the person's left
side similarly here this is the right
and this is the left main bronchus
getting back the bronchi entered the
respective lungs to get further divided
into bronchioles now before we talk
about the lungs and the surrounding
protective case let's continue with the
bronchioles and the
terminal structures the bronchioles are
these smaller
root-like structures that are present
inside the lungs
these ultimately lead to the bundles of
these tiny sacs any idea what are these
structures that appear like cluster of
grapes
well these sacs form the basic units of
the respiratory system they are the
actual sites of the gaseous exchange
that is the exchange of oxygen and
carbon dioxide between the lungs and the
blood occurs in the alveoli one single
ball like this one is called the
alveolus any idea why these alveoli have
these several spherical ball like
structures why isn't a single alveolus a
complete ball well many smaller balls
help in increasing the surface area
imagine this single ball suppose it has
the surface area of X meter squared now
if the same volume is occupied by 25
smaller bowls it's obvious that the
surface area will increase by many folds
similarly here as well the number of
smaller structures make sure that the
surface area increases and the maximum
surface gets available for the gaseous
exchange if we zoom in to see a single
alveoli we find that the cluster is
richly supplied with blood capillaries a
cross sectional view of a single
alveolus helps us understand that it's
very thin and composed of a single
celled memory the extremely thin
membrane helps in very easy exchange of
gases between the alveolus and the RBC's
flowing through the capillaries the
process of gas exchange occurs wire
diffusion so oxygen that has come to
this alveolus gets diffused across the
membrane and is grabbed by the RBC's
once this is done the carbon dioxide
also gets into the alveoli via diffusion
and this carbon dioxide travels back the
complete tract to reach the nostrils and
move out of the body this is how the
gaseous exchange occurs in
each alveoli now that we know how the
components of the respiratory system
present inside the lungs work let us
focus on the lungs and the other
remaining components of the lower
respiratory tract
let's lunda in the next part
[Music]